so while we start with the session i
request you all to please
uh keep your microphones on mute
now talking about today's session
precision medicine is changing the way
we
understand diagnose and uh treat major
life-threatening diseases
and this transformation is driven by
high throughput molecular data
that is being collected from patients
animal models
and large-scale cell line experiments
and in this program bioinformatics for
precision medicine
we would explore how the various omics
data types generated in these studies
can be analyzed and integrated to study
the basic biology associated with the
viruses
and their hosts cancer onset and the
development and outcomes as well
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager
and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are
part of a bioinformatics community
managed by
pine biotech so before we start with
today's session i would want to
introduce us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop
easy to use accessible tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
our mixed logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between
buying biotech and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omics logic is an international program
that is currently running in five
different regions
with over ten 000 users around the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and reshare
coordinators
that are helping refine local program
logistics
and leverage our online training
resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
this online program includes weekly
sessions with an instructor
online tracking and review of student
progress
access to all the resources and
materials online for
self-paced learning access to expert
guidance
and problem solving educational and
research pipelines
and domain data analysis on our big data
server let me introduce you to the
program mentors
we have dr harpreet with us she has an
expertise in the application of
statistical machine learning techniques
on biomedical data and the development
of prediction tools and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumba is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications and peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in industry and
academia
and over the past several years he has
been developing collaborations with
universities
as a mentor and project lead for
omix-logic training and research
fellowship
and dr japoniano chevas he is a
post-structural fellow
at university of chicago he is killed in
bioinformatics and is an expert in
glioblastoma
now i would want to invite elia brodsky
ceo pine biotech to discuss
further about the session over to
eugenia
thank you very much and great to have
all of you
here today so today we'll
talk about our first session for
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and i want to begin with
a brief introduction to what precision
medicine is
so maybe i can ask that question to all
of you
again thank you for joining i would like
to ask
all of you i'm sure that many of you
have the background and the expertise
and the interest in precision medicine
how would you define precision medicine
so if you could
use the chat to type in your answers i
would love to know what you think
so what is the definition of precision
medicine
hello hello yes huh
yeah a medicine which
cured the patient with minimal side
effects
okay excellent thank you uh
mentioned that this is a method of
disease treatment
uh saran is mentioning that personalized
medicine based on pharmacogenomics
excellent enzyme asp
is saying that this is the use of tools
and approaches
in a more personalized way
all right excellent so great answers
everyone and
i think that we can turn to
formal definition of what is
personalized
medicine and what is precision medicine
because there's actually a distinction
between the two
okay excellent someone else is adding
here chiang mai is saying medicine's
engineered to specific genotypes as to
enhance
efficacy gerald
medical solutions specific to the
genetic characteristics of an individual
all right vinay is saying customized
drug to each individual
so excellent answers let me read out the
formal definition
so precision medicine is an emerging
approach for disease treatment and
prevention
that takes into account individual
variable
gene environment and lifestyle
for each person this approach will allow
doctors and researchers to predict
more accurately which treatment and
prevention strategies for a particular
disease
will work in which groups of people it
is
in contrast to a one size fit all
approach
in which disease treatment and
prevention strategies are developed for
the average person
with less consideration for the
differences between individuals
so as you can see the personalized and
the
precision part of it are actually
intertwined and what's important is that
after
decades of research we now know that
the detailed genetic and other molecular
information about a patient's condition
can be and should be used to deploy
effective patient specific remedies
unfortunately the overall statement
that we are describing here is very
um much a broad statement that
lacks certain details and those details
is what we want to
focus on in this program but this is a
good point for us to start this
discussion because
ultimately we mentioned the genotyping
so we
mentioned genes and specific genomic
information
we mentioned lifestyle and other types
of
variable factors that can affect the
treatment efficacy
or outcomes and can also help us detect
disease early so we'll talk about these
aspects as well
and importantly what combines
all of these factors is that these
factors come from data
so today this data is superficial
based on symptoms that are categorized
with
clinical broad terms and we are moving
towards a more precise division of these
terms
using molecular phenotypes and molecular
data
so before we continue speaking about
precision medicine
briefly about myself and about our
company
we are a technology transfer company uh
the company originated at the university
of haifa in israel
and the uh company co-founders dr alfred
tauber and dr lena brodsky
combined the vision for precision
medicine and
the significant role that bioinformatics
plays
in precision medicine where the need to
integrate multi-omics data is a
very important part and a cutting edge
of research that
is of interest to many different
clintons as well as researchers around
the world
but this research effort has been taken
into a
broader to the broader audience by our
team
our team includes people that work on
curriculum design
that help design delivery methods to
make this
content available online it also
includes programmers and
bioinformaticians that are skilled
in analysis of various types of data and
overall our mission
is to make data science
available for a broader audience
so the overall theme of the omixlogic
programs
is that we are focused on biology as a
data science
developing applications of high
throughput data analysis
to allow participants of all backgrounds
to utilize them and solve the need for
data literacy in application to
biomedical
challenges and so here you can see some
areas including
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience as well as agriculture
so to address this challenge we actually
have designed kind of the three pillars
of what our programs are all about
so the goal of onyx logic is to provide
training
in bioinformatics guided by mentors and
peer example
we want to grow a community that
shares a passion for data-driven
research in an appreciation for
citizen science and we want to help
students clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology in the life of data science
and so we have been working on enabling
research using
these three things big data analysis
tools that are easy to use and train
people to use them effectively
provide mentorship by building a network
of mentors that are available
for answering your questions and guiding
your research
and then providing training and so this
program is one of the examples of
a training program that is designed to
provide you with very specific learning
outcomes
and briefly i will mention also how we
will achieve that
for those of you that are joining this
program so one of the outcomes that is
very important in this
precision medicine topic is the basic
understanding of scientific literature
that describes analysis of omnics data
through the lens of precision medicine
we will go through
project examples and literature that
will help you understand this topic not
from me
but from experts that have spent years
researching these topics
and together we will learn how they have
applied
bioinformatics methods effectively to
extract meaningful
and translational ideas that are
applicable in the clinical sense
we will also focus on basic processing
steps for next generation sequencing
data analysis
with consistent accuracy so
independently you can conduct such
analysis
we will perform exploratory analysis and
generate a hypothesis from data or
data-driven research we'll focus on that
and you will be able to think about the
different categories
and factors in your data to design
contrasts for statistical tests
and prepare data for machine learning
you will also be able to annotate
found signal using biological databases
and references
identify appropriate data sets for
answering a biological question
plan your bioinformatics analysis from
start to finish independently
and present a project proposal including
the rationale
the methods scientific background and
anticipated results so these are really
the objectives for this program in the
context of
precision medicine or how does
bioinformatics
play a role in precision medicine
and to help us with all of this we have
this network of
mentors that will be accessible
throughout the summer
i will briefly we will briefly introduce
each one of them
throughout the next several programs
that we have
and the summer training programs are
designed to actually lead to
a research project and for those of you
that are considering this path
we have multiple programs available that
include
precision medicine source cove 2 data
analysis
we have programs on data science focused
on technical skills like coding and
machine learning
and we also have a research fellowship
program and the research fellowship
program
is a special opportunity that provides
you with hands-on
support and a research focused
group of people that can plan and
actually execute the analysis that
they're planning and develop
a research project in a short time now
for all of you that are already a part
of the research fellowship or are
planning to find
a research fellowship that fits your
needs we welcome you to first join a
training program like this one
and then in the future as you might be
interested to work
more on a research project you can join
the research fellowship
for those that are working already on
project or and would like to join
a research symposium in august august
21st to 22nd we will have
a specially designed omics research
symposium that is organized with our
partners
at the louisiana biomedical research
network georgetown university
university of haifa and many others that
will provide you with an opportunity
to highlight your achievement through a
poster session and presentation of your
project
prizes and also to learn about
cutting-edge research and applications
of bioinformatics
undergraduate masters and phd programs
in bioinformatics including for
international
students we will offer also a glimpse of
what the recruiters and industry are
looking for
in those that are willing to apply for a
position
how do you get into an internship or how
do you identify job opportunities if you
have been trained in bioinformatics
and also we will discuss some effective
resources for training in education and
bioinformatics and data science
and obviously there will be prizes for
the best high school college
and citizen science research project so
we're excited
and we're looking forward towards this
and all of you that are joining this
session
if you're a part of our training
programs or not you are welcome to join
and
we will be sending out information on
this soon
so now let me turn to bioinformatics for
precision medicine
so this is our first session and in
today's session we will talk about
translational bioinformatics approaches
that lead to
effective outcomes and help address the
gaps
in precision medicine and let's start by
talking a little bit about the future of
medicine so what is the future of
medicine and where are we
to actually facilitate some progress
in this so i think that it is obvious
that to make these
better decisions about patients and
treatments and outcomes
there has to be aggregation of data
and there has to be an integration
between
lab data research data and data coming
from the patients
and all of this data has to be presented
to experts that understand the data in
such a way that they can
discuss the results of analysis in a
meaningful way
and they can translate this information
to practical decisions that they have to
make
leading to an effective identification
of
areas of research that then could be
addressed
by pharmaceutical companies
biotechnology companies
and others that are involved in
addressing
the unmet needs and so what we
see this is as a combination of personal
and precise and there has to be
a number of components that come
together to make that possible
so beyond the general statements like we
have
discussed up until now let's talk about
how does this actually play out
in different examples so most people
would agree that
we can separate divide the diseases into
two kinds
infectious diseases and non-infectious
diseases so infectious diseases
are spread directly or indirectly from
one person to another
caused by pathogenic microorganisms such
as bacteria viruses parasites or fungi
and non-infectious diseases are not
caused by a pathogen and cannot be
shared from one person to another
they're caused by environments
nutritional deficiencies
lifestyle choices and genetic
inheritance
and so to study these diseases we can
leverage
data that is widely available
and what i wanted to do today is take a
look at some of these examples
to kind of identify what types of data
and
what types of analysis is appropriate
for each type of data
so that we have a sense of what might be
the source of information
and the application of the information
that we derive from such data
so omix data in infectious disease
research can include
viral genomics and evolution and we all
know that this is a very
relevant topic today as we are in the
middle of a pandemic
and actually not just this pandemic but
we live
in an era of series of epidemics
starting from source one flu as you
remember bird flu
ebola virus outbreaks rhinovirus is now
again reappearing so we live
in an era of epidemics and pandemics and
understanding
the pathogens that cause this in a
precise way
is a component of precision medicine
or precision public health we also
understand now
different drivers of infection and
responses and those include our micro
environment
including the microbiome and immune
responses
and markers of the immune responses that
we can detect in patients
and ultimately when we speak about
infectious diseases
in a lot of ways we are talking about
again
extracting meaningful signal from the
data
so that it can be made available to
decision makers that can
look at the data in an intuitive way so
they have to be presented with that data
in an intuitive way
but also they have to be trained to be
able to ask
questions research questions based on
the data that they
see and lead to important
research topics that can be addressed
effectively
in the lab in the research world and by
translational industry which means
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
industry as well as the clinicians
that can actually take some finding in
the
in that research realm and translate it
to practice
so the other topic that we mentioned are
non-infectious diseases and
non-infectious diseases is a good
example for us to start with
where molecular information and
sequencing information plays a huge role
is cancer and as we all know cancer
is a growing concern we're much more
informed about cancer and what's obvious
today about cancer is that
there's a huge difference between types
of cancer
between the people that are affected
with different types of cancer
and the drivers of cancer
in the whole population around the world
and one of the clear signs is that
we know now that the cancer is
associated with aging
a lot of cancers are affecting older
people
and so as they become more
risk susceptible we need to understand
how do we prevent and how do we treat
this cancer more effectively
and one of the things that is very
important in this is the ability to
identify
cancer onset and stratify patients
according to risk
according to outcomes and
make sure that we incorporate this
information in the treatment plan
and one of those is to identify markers
of cancer risk so before we go on
i have a few questions based on what we
just discussed today
so what do you think are some examples
of
omnics data that can help us
study these conditions including
infectious diseases
and cancer what is an example of
omix data that is used in such research
so
if you think about different types of
omics data maybe you're familiar with
different types of omics data
you can write it out in the chat or if
you would like to unmute yourself and
say it
that is also fine so what is an example
of omnics data
okay so saran is mentioning metabolomics
dr sudha transcriptomics anushka jane is
also
saying transcriptomics okay excellent
ngs
ngs can be used to
generate multiple types of omix data
okay dr sudhi is saying genomics
metabolomics okay gwas is a method of
analysis that's good
metabolomics okay anyone else
what other so we mentioned
transcriptomics and metabolomics and
genomics three
any other types of omics data just
based on what we discussed already
epigenomics okay
so that's four what else proteomics
five lipidomic six metagenomics
okay excellent excellent i i think we
covered a lot of
epigenomics excellent okay what kind of
information
can we learn from transcriptomic data
okay so let's take one of these
what kind of information can we learn
from transcriptomic data so there's
okay excellent gene expression okay so
what
gene expression is the information that
we extract from transcriptomic data
excellent
what are some of the challenges with
analysis of omics data
okay integration so fernanda fernando is
saying integration
zara is saying snips so snips i i'm
assuming you're referring to
what kind of information that is true we
can extract
the dominant snips from transcriptomic
data but more likely you're speaking
about genomic
data but what are some challenges with
analysis of omix data so fernando
already mentioned
integration that's an excellent
challenge right how do we
take these different types of sequences
and we extract genomic data
transcriptomic data
and all kinds of other data and
integrate them to understand what's
really going on
okay what what else what else do you
think are some of the challenges and
danilo
is also mentioning isoforms long
non-coding rnas micrornas okay excellent
danilo thank you
so what are some of the challenges with
analysis of vomiting state
all right thank you fernando saying
computational requirements right this is
big data now that we have thousands of
patients
and each patient is generating some
genomic
transcriptomic metagenomic data now we
run into a problem of computational
resources
okay what additional challenges are
there
for okay data management exactly i've
analyzed this
i've analyzed that i have some tables
where did they come from how did i
generate them right
all of the data management questions
come to mind
okay great thank you everyone for your
questions last challenge
okay this is not for today
advances in next generation sequencing
so we talked about
omix data and a lot of the omics data is
coming from a very specific type of a
technology so
once it was discovered that the dna
encodes for genes that are then
transcribed into rna
that are then translated into protein we
now know
that next generation sequencing
represents an
excellent opportunity to study these
molecular mechanisms of regulation
that lead to specific phenotypes
and ultimately we even mentioned here
proteomics lipidonics
metabolomics all of these are functional
enzymes and molecules and
proteins that define the phenotype but
whatever is encoded in the dna and the
way that it is
translated into proteins and all of
these elements
that is the machinery that we can study
to understand what is really going on
and the unique part
about next generation sequencing is that
the cost
of next generation sequencing has been
dropping very steadily over time so
if you think back to 2001
we started from a hundred million
dollars for the full genome to sequence
the full genome and
16 years later in 2017 for the first
time
the price of the genome the whole genome
sequence
was just around one thousand dollars and
so
because of that not only is this data
informative it can give us insights into
what's going on
but it is also accessible and affordable
and
it is approaching that threshold that
makes it comparable to some of the other
tests that are being done
in the clinic already and we've been
using them for a long time
and so to really understand that we can
look at the history of genomic data
which started in the 1950s when the
double helix structure was uh understood
and then very rapidly if you think up
until 2018
we've already had thousands of genomes
that have been sequenced for hundreds of
thousands of patients around the world
and so as you can see the price
the reduction in price led to an
explosion
of omics data that is now available
in research for companies in
biotechnology and pharmaceutical
industry
as well as in the clinic and so
to talk a little bit about the different
types of omics data we can mention
that there are many different types of
omics data that we can extract
based on sequencing and to understand
the relationship between
genotype or what is found in the
sequence and the phenotype
the first one is phenomics we know that
cells
function and look very differently
tissues they form different tissues
if you take a look at the morphology of
a cell it can tell you
that there's a huge difference in the
way that it functions between let's say
liver and blood right i mean think about
it one is a
solid tissue and one is a liquid
one performs one function another one
performs another function so
obviously that dna that contains
information
on how to make those cells includes all
kinds of recipes
that we can study and understand what is
the potential
of all of these genes to perform
different types of functions
but ultimately because of the phenotype
differences we know that not all of
these genes are
equally activated and so we have to go
beyond just what's encoded in the dna
and we have to look at how is that dna
regulated and so this is a growing
area of research since about 2009 2010
there has been a tremendous interest in
epigenomic
data because it reveals epigenetic
regulation
how do these genes become more
accessible how
do they change from one isoform
to another isoform and so that
regulation
is called epigenomics that data like
chronic immunoprecipitation like whole
genome bisulfite sequencing
and many others microrna etc can really
reveal that
mechanism of regulation and then finally
we have transcriptomic data
which allows us to understand what has
actually been transcribed from the
messenger rna
and how can we study the various
isoforms
and transcripts that are being present
in a sample
now ultimately what does this lead us to
this data
leads us to a change in the way a
clinician
can look at a condition so if you think
of this
iceberg as a condition a patient that
comes in
and says my head hurts or i have a lump
and so on top on the surface what we
know
is that there's some clinical data that
might be available
but beneath the surface there are these
layers
of omics data that can reveal
the molecular properties driving
this top of the iceberg clinical
phenotype
that the patients are describing or that
we can capture with
tests like blood tests and
imaging and other types of uh
traditional
forms of generating clinical data now
what's underneath the tip of the iceberg
underneath the tip of the iceberg we
have the transcription
the translation and the result of that
translation
at as the protein and so what we know
now is that
we can take a look at specific proteins
that are critical for us to identify
patients that will respond
to certain therapies like the her2
protein
that help us categorize specific
patients into subgroups and understand
a lot better why certain patients
have different responses to treatment or
have
different prediction or different
anticipation of
recovery and remission so one of the
examples for these
is the evolution of breast cancer
classification so we know
that breast cancer is actually a complex
disease
includes many different tissues in the
breast that are affected
and they also have different properties
they grow at different rates they have
different success
at treatment and so when we think about
breast cancer
classification we now can separate
breast cancers
into multiple subtypes of the actual
disease
based on protein expression based on
gene expression
based on different types of risks found
in the genome
and different types of mutations that
are found in the genome
and so one of the ways that we will use
this example is to really look for
how does the prognosis
response to treatment stratification of
patients drug
purposing diagnosis target discovery and
risk prediction
are all components of precision medicine
that we are all anticipating and so
here's a glimpse
of how we can study uh cancer
using these kinds of technologies we can
look at
uh understanding of risk early on
so the earlier the better we can address
the problem that we
are anticipating we can also look at
likelihood of response to treatment
we can look at different types of drug
safety parameters better
and so we can optimize the treatment
prevention and prognosis
ultimately for patients and hopefully
make sure that this disease is bringing
lower mortality in a longer healthier
lifespan for patients
but at the core of this problem is the
integration of data so at the core of
this
we need to understand how all of these
pieces of data bioinformatics chemo
informatics
clinical data how do all of them tie
together to provide us with
a better sense of diagnostics and
therapeutics
and the problem is that this is really
creating a gap
and a gap in understanding as well as
a gap in industries that are trying to
address this gap and so the way that i
think that
this data gap is
disrupting industries and why
there's a growing need in people like
yourselves that are learning
bioinformatics and that are learning
translational bioinformatics
is because all of these industries which
are huge industries
have to adapt to this new status which
is
that everything is data driven and the
data is becoming more complex
and so as we think about this we really
should turn
to how does this information coming from
research
get translated to actual useful
information
that and how is its information being
used
and so i think what we will do in this
program is we will start thinking about
how
experiments that are performed in the
lab with tissue culture and cell lines
how can they inform the understanding of
cancer and a systems biology that we can
study in patient-derived genograph
models and animal models
how do these insights can get translated
to
actual practical applications that are
applicable to patients
in clinical trials where we can test
drug responses and improve the outcomes
as well as to the clinic and one of the
primary ways that this
is being done is actually not even in
the practice realm
but first of all it is in the realm of
design
and the design has to do with
data driven instead of a biological
hypothesis based approach right so
today the information is top down
so someone that has studied this topic
a particular type of cancer a particular
type of a condition
is thinking and learning from
experiments and accumulates this
knowledge and then designs
experiments based on their understanding
and that is hypothesis
based we take a textbook approach we
identify some important critical portion
and we design an experiment to validate
on the flip side of that of that is the
big data approach and the big data
approach is really saying
i have all of these accessible data sets
i can sample them
and sequence them and understand what is
going on
to start asking the questions
how do i address a particular variation
that i have found
or how does this affect patients that i
know of and so that is really what this
program is going to be all about
how do we change your thinking to a
data-driven approach
to the research data sets that are
available online
linking them to clinical information
that we can also find online
and that link helping us to think of
a big data approach to different types
of conditions and diseases
and patients that could ultimately
benefit from
better treatment earlier prediction and
better prognosis of outcomes
now i want to explain exactly how
can you benefit the most from joining
the program
by identifying specific steps that you
need to take
from this session up until the next
session
to get access to everything that you
will need to
practice the technical and the hands-on
activities that we will do
and to learn all of the material and so
to talk about that
i want to ask uh sonalika to
again talk us walk us through
how we can get access to all of the
resources that are needed
thank you so much helia
yes so first of all i would want you all
to
sign up on the portal learn dot omits
logic i will be sharing the link with
you all
if you all have signed up then just let
me walk you through how to update your
profile
and things ahead but if you have not
let's
give you two minutes to please sign up
this is the link
learn.amislogic.com i would want you
all to please sign up here you can sign
up either by creating your mail id and a
password for yourself
or also you can sign up via your social
but i would recommend you sign up
creating a password for yourself
and while others are signing up
i would want to take few of the things
those who have already signed up
please login to your profile and
i would want to know in the chat box if
you have signed up by
either sending a one or a yes so that i
know who all have completed their sign
up
so um so if you could please go to the
main page and just show from the
beginning
once people get on the portal how do
they actually take the steps to
make sure that they're registered thank
you yes
thank you so you can sign up either by
your id
and create a password for yourself or
via social
and let me just show how you can do so
via social
thank you for letting me know that you
have signed up
and those who have not they can sign up
with me because that is what you would
be required to go further in the process
for the program
thank you everyone
and now as you all have signed up like i
see many yes
those who are signed up i would want you
to take
to go through the update uh to update
your profile
and while i'm guiding the ones who have
signed up to update their profile
others can sign up in the meanwhile yes
so those who have signed up i would want
them to update
their profile and also link in their
social
accounts linking in the social accounts
would help
us feature you all with your progress on
our social sites
and also uh we have a lot many
recruiters so
uh seeing your progress we could
also take your profile ahead
and highlight them in front of the
recruiters that would be a great help to
you as well
and please ensure that as a part of the
program you are a part of the
bioinformatics for
precision medicine program you must see
a
batch of precision medicine here on your
profile
this is for those who have already
registered and are a part of the program
and please ensure that you have a
starter subscription
accessed with your account if yes and
please send a yes
anushka gerald i can see you have said
yes as well please check this and please
let me know
that uh please ensure you have a starter
batch and also you have the bash for the
program and also update your profile
picture and link can be social
once your profile is updated and you can
see your activity
uh on the profile itself
and also you would be able to get these
certificates once you complete
the given number of assignments for the
program
and also to go ahead with the project so
we would also take you
further to complete your project and
upload it in the later part of the
session but this is
where you can just look at your activity
and get the certificates as well and
also look at the courses and the
programs that you all
have covered so if you all have
completed your sign
up sahara says no batches only starter
subscription
okay zara i'll look into it and zahara
are you enrolled for the precision
medicine program
i'm sorry we have not received our
enrollment yet
so if you have then please mail me at
marketing at the rate buying dot bio so
that i
cross check i should not be missing out
on any of the enrollments
i believe now everyone has completed
their sign up and if not then i'll share
the link again and you can do so
uh meanwhile or maybe later
now this is the program page with which
you have to
keep a check on and just share the
program page link
this is the program page by which you
have to register yourself
now if you hover over the program page
we have mentioned all the session
details in the page itself which has the
calendar
so you would be you would stay updated
with all the dates
of the session and also the session
details on which day what session would
be covered
and on the program page in the session
details itself you would have the
zoom link here and also the recording of
the session would be
uh published on the program page after
each session is over so let's say after
this session the first session
i would be uploading the recording of
the first session on the program page so
that you can go through the recording
if you miss out something and then take
your doubts right
and all those who have enrolled that
already a part of the program page
so please make it sure that by tomorrow
you can see the
recording of the session and uh
those who have not yet completed their
registration process and would want to
proceed further with the registration
on the same program page they would get
the option of the levels figure
intermediate and advanced now these
levels we have segregated
on the basis of the provisions provided
you can just go through all the
provisions which would be
provided as a part of the program for
these three different
levels and those who are a part of an
intermediate and advanced
level they would get to uh do a research
project
under our mentor and they can uh
further we would be guiding them further
for how their research project has to be
covered ahead and how they have to uh
like
go on from finding a data set and then
working on it doing the analysis
and then finally uh publishing their
work so we'll take them through
everything
towards the middle end those who are a
part of intimidate and the advanced
levels
and as a part of the program you would
also get the access
to a lot of asynchronous course material
on the portal and the courses to which
the access would be given as a part of
the program are mentioned here on the
program page
and the certificate which would be uh
given for the program is
mentioned here is shown here as well and
this is what the format of the
certificate looks like
and as a part of the program uh you
would also get the access to the t
buyer info server on which different
sorts of pipelines would be carried out
and the
analysis would be done uh our mentors
would be taking you through
uh the pipelines as well and how you
have to
uh go ahead with each and every analysis
now those who have enrolled for them it
is
to know that your login credentials
for the learn portal and the server
would be the same that is you
you must be able to login with your same
id and password as
that of learn on the t by info server as
well
and if you face any of the issues then
do let us know
we'll have a look and this is the
detailed syllabus
because i know you all must be excited
to know about the
syllabus topics would be for each and
every session
so this is the detailed syllabus page
i'll share the link of the syllabus page
as well
and you can go through all of the
associated online resources which you
will get as a part of each and every
session
too and to your knowledge we are also
there on linkedin and facebook i would
want you
to be a part of our linkedin and
facebook page so that you stay updated
with all the upcoming
uh other opportunities as well and also
stay
updated uh with who is doing the best
like i told you that we would be
featuring your profiles with the
performance
on our pages and we are there on
linkedin by the name of onyx logic
i'll share the link again and on
facebook we are there by the name of
pine biotech
and uh i'll just take a second more we
are at present live on youtube so if you
would want to
go back and look at some of the uh
things which india mentioned you can go
to the link and watch the recording
oh what do you mean thank you thank you
very much
so i um i'm going to show
once you are logged in so again for
those of you that
have completed your registration when
you go
to the program link in sonarika if you
could again post the program
page on the program page you will find
the information that is already
relevant to what we are doing today so
right here you will see
the zoom link for example for our next
session
you will find the zoom link here once we
approach
july 8th and after today's session is
over
and after you are done with today's
session you can click on
complete session by marking this session
as complete
you will start getting points towards
your
certificate so you can now see that i
have one out of 10 sessions complete
and as you go through these you will
also see for the completed ones that we
have already done instead of the zoom
after the session is over this will
become a video
now as soon as i mentioned here you have
the different resources
and down at the bottom we also have a
slack channel
so if you have joined you can go to
ask the question and this should open up
slack if you already have an account
you should be able to open slack
directly just like i'm doing right now
and if you don't have an account on
slack it's a free account
and you get to join our community of all
of the participants
so here you can see that all of you that
have joined
you should be a part of this slack
channel now on the slide channel
we will post important information about
practical assignments if you have any
questions you can ask them there
we will be posting the recorded sessions
and all of the needed
information in a timely way will be
updated right here
so again this is just a way for you to
be connected to all of the different
resources
and also you will find here a way to
book a meeting with us or ask questions
and also see your certificate but all of
this is
around your personal profile so really
as i mentioned
try to complete this profile as soon as
possible
okay so let me now go and talk a little
bit about
why this program is going to be focused
on data and how we're going to address
this problem
so the three things that our program is
going to provide you with
are the tools the skills and the ideas
about how to apply these tools
and data sets to different types of
challenges
and ultimately we're going to provide
you with a number of examples
of how you can take cellular omics data
understand the challenge in the
integration
and then try to understand the
relationship between clinical and
phenotypic data
with the different levels of onyx data
that
we will describe in detail including
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic data and others and as you
can imagine the obvious challenge
with this is that you are going to be
faced with many different technical
challenges that
are going to be difficult for those of
you that do not come from an engineering
background so here i would like to ask
you a question
about your background okay
so i know that we have participants with
different degrees so you could be a high
school student or a bachelor student
or a master's student or maybe
a phd or faculty so if you could please
post in the chat box right now what is
your
level of education your current level of
education
high school bachelor's degree master's
degree
phd or if you're a faculty
okay excellent thank you phd
master's phd faculty master's in
biotechnology faculty
masters in computer science excellent
master's in biochemistry
master's in biochemistry
okay i'll just give it a couple more
minutes phd
masters in technology and bioinformatics
okay excellent
okay so one of the challenges
in bioinformatics is that there are a
lot of
methods algorithmic methods there are a
lot of different types of data
and there are also a lot of things that
are not well defined so their
data wrangling data visualization
different types of
approaches to scripting that require
everyone to be
aware of how to just deal with data
what's called data literacy
and i think on the flip side on the
engineering side
what is oftentimes not clear to people
coming from an engineering background is
how do these methods of computer
software essentially
address the problems in biology and so
this program is really designed to
bring those two together to take the
biological terminology
and the computer science slash
engineering
aspects of bioinformatics and bring them
closer together
and to do that we want to make sure that
everyone is familiar with some of the
basic ideas about biological
background as well as the basics
of computational and data science
skills that you need to have and to do
that
we have designed a number of courses
that you should start with
so let me share some of those with you
okay so if you go to the courses tab
you will find here some important
coursework
that you can start with as you are
getting started with this program or
any other program that we have for those
of you coming from an engineering
background
we recommend a course called bytes and
molecules
it will introduce you to some of the
basic terminology
and give you a sense of what is a
mutation what is gene expression
how do we use this information to answer
biological questions
for those of you that are not familiar
with bioinformatics
we recommend to get started with this
course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and that will give you some perspective
on the applications of bioinformatics
in general like the introduction to big
data bioinformatics how do we start
thinking with this
data driven instead of a hypothesis
driven research
how is bioinformatics used in healthcare
and biomedical research
and then also what is translational
bioinformatics so
if you have just registered recently or
you
are now registering
please make sure that you start with
these courses
okay so um again you create a profile
and once you create a profile this is a
free course so anyone can take this
and once you have completed this course
again you can click
always on your name right here
and you can go to the course tab to see
your progress
with different courses so by next time
that we meet
please make sure that you have completed
introduction to bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules so these are
going to be important courses for you to
complete
so that we can all continue and move
forward
now the other side of things is that you
will need
access to our big data analysis platform
okay so let me briefly explain how it
works
and what we will do using a
short example okay please go to this
link server.tbio.info
for those of you that registered today
you probably don't have your access yet
for those of you that have registered
previously starting from yesterday
you should be able to use your omixlogic
login details your email and your
password to be able to get in
so please let me know once you're logged
in you should be able to see
your name right here your email address
right here under your profile
okay put number one if you can log in
or no so number one or yes if you can
log in
number two or no if you cannot log in
okay so dr sudha again given that you
have created
an account on omixlogic not today
so if you just created your account
today you still don't have access
it takes up to 24 hours for your profile
to be created on the big data analysis
platform but for those of you that have
registered a while ago yesterday or
before that
you should already have your login okay
so anjali pravin uh dr
sudha i am assuming you just registered
today
correct
anushka yes so if you just registered
today
you will not have access but you can
still follow along and then tomorrow you
can replicate the same steps so
your free account will come with this
information so let me briefly introduce
you
to what we can do on this portal
and to do that i will take an example
project
that we will go through in our
discussions
okay so uh gerald when did you
sign up okay
so gerald if you can try and
uh sonalika maybe you could help uh
gerald
uh he should have his account set up
already if he doesn't maybe dr harpreet
can help him
okay so once you're in you will see that
this is a
big data analysis environment that
you can use to try out a number of
different approaches
to analysis of big data
and instead of going into the main
section what we will do is we will open
it up
as a drop down and we will take at this
cell line project the first project
right here
so once you're inside you will see that
this is a graph
of different methods each box here
represents an
algorithm and this algorithm has a
logical
purpose that logical purpose is stated
in the box above
so when we take raw sequencing data we
would like to
clean this data we would then like to
map it on the genome
make sure that we are capturing the
isoforms and recording them in the gtf
file
mapping this information on transcript
so we know transcript
abundance by quantifying expression
levels
and then performing differential gene
expression or even just preparing our
table of expression for downstream
analysis and so to illustrate
how you can go from raw data to
structure data
i will just demonstrate a brief
step-by-step process
where we start we clean up the data
with trim-o-matic and pcr clean
we then can map onto the genome
isoform construction using cufflinks
add that information to the gtf file
using gtf processing
mapping on transcripts using bowtie2t
preparing an rsm gene expression table
that looks like this
and then we can actually click on end
to see the output files and so here you
will see a number of
different outputs so in a similar way
what we will do in this program is we
will go through genomic data
transcriptomic data meta genomic data
and introduce you to some of the common
tools and methods that you need to
understand
and place them in the right position in
the bioinformatics pipeline
to get meaningful results does anyone
have any questions about this before i
go on
okay the second thing that you will be
introduced to
are some data repositories
so we will not just take data sets that
we give you but we will actually
introduce you to repositories where you
can find
data independently does anyone here
have any sense of where to find data
about cancer onyx data about cancer
i'll give you a hint one of the
repositories is right there on the
screen
all right excellent c bio portal tcga
excellent so what is tcga
what kind of data do we have on tcga
leena
okay cancer genome atlas so dr sudhan
okay what kind of data do we actually
have on tcga
okay the answer is we have patient data
so they're
a number of different tumors that
exactly cancer genomic data cancer
transcriptomic data so it's multi-omics
data
that has been integrated so we can
easily search and find different types
of data but beyond that
there are also data sets on ncbi for
example
national center for biotechnology
information so we will
also go through some research papers
that describe applications
of cancer cell line and patient-derived
xenograft models or animal models that
we can use
to find interesting insights like
biomarkers
that have a computational component to
them
and allow us to predict outcomes for
different types of treatment response
so we will take a look at some of those
data sets in the tcga data sets
we will take a look at the association
between clinical information
and genomic information as well as other
other types of omics
and ultimately we will also take a look
at some infectious disease research
challenges where we can identify
important
information about infectious diseases
and the pathogens that cause them
as well as the immune responses so as a
result
you will find important information on
how to perform standard analysis
like phylogenetic analysis gene
expression
composition analysis of
alignment and variant calling insights
into structural biology
and how to integrate all of these data
sets so we will talk about those and
what i recommend to get started is to
start looking
at some of the important project
examples that we will be using
throughout this program okay where do
you find them
again you go to courses and you can
start looking through some of the
examples right here for example
tcga liver cancer project on precision
oncology
or covenanting origin and pathogenesis
of source code 2.
so if you have an interest in cancer
type data
or in infectious diseases you can find
some project examples
okay so finally i want to mention again
that
all of this information is going to go
towards your own individual progress so
even though this is a program it brings
you together as a group
the objective is for you to grow
personally and we hope that you will be
able
to develop an independent project so
how do you go from learning about these
skills
and trying out different examples to
actually
developing an independent project
astronautic already mentioned
we have a system designed to help you
go from learning to then application
and that will be focused on the aspect
of developing a bioinformatics project
so we hope that this program will help
you start
conceive of a project and then start
thinking about how you actually conduct
the analysis that you have planned
so if you're a phd you're already
working in some kind of a
project where you have omics data you
want to integrate it this is not just
going to be learning about
bioinformatics this is going to be
let's do bioinformatics let's get this
done and let's apply these tools
to a data set of your own and for that
you
need to have the advanced account
and advanced registration for the
program or
you can participate in the research
fellowship program as
a additional level to your subscription
with this program
and then pursue your project
independently so
before we leave i want to leave you
with this slide where you will find
important courses that you can start
with
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules
as well as some information about how to
get started
with bioinformatics in python and in r
and how to design a bioinformatics
research project so if you're coming
from a life science background
how do you actually think about
selecting a topic finding that data set
and then applying what you learn in this
program to design
an independent bioinformatics research
program and once you start making
progress
you will see that on this page you have
some simple steps
for you to get to a level where you can
conduct a project independently
with our support and then publish it on
here
as a featured project and just to give
you a sense of what that looks like if
you scroll all the way to the bottom of
this page
you will find here a couple of examples
glioblastoma
covid19 drug repurposing and lymphocytic
leukemia
will give you a good sense of what you
can come out with
as you develop these project ideas
during this program
so that's all we wanted to share in
terms of today's session
so malik i will pass it on back to you
if you have anything to add before we
close and if anyone has any questions
that i can answer
please put them in the chat and we'll be
happy to see you again next time
thank you so much ilya and thank you so
much everyone so listening
uh for listening so patiently so today
we discussed about the role of
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and in the next sessions we would be
going through the practical aspects and
also we'll take you through the project
samples and go forward with carrying out
the analysis
and also we would be talking about next
generation sequencing and big data
analysis
and then we would go towards discussing
the applications for
infectious diseases that would be viral
and bacterial infections
and then also discuss about the armies
data the role of omits data
in cancer research be it genomics
transcriptomics or epigenetics
and we would be waiting for you all
to interact with in the next sessions
thank you for joining today
and so yes so we have few questions
thank you easier for answering
also there was one question i think it
went and answered let me take that
and um you can ask the questions if you
have any sort of in the chat box right
now
we can answer it them for you
so just about the software i want to
clarify
uh if you are going to participate in
all of the sessions
in future sessions you will require some
software like
integrative genome uh browser
um you will be able to browse
uh vcf files and see how we can identify
mutations that are present in some
samples so we will have
some of that software that is described
in the projects that we will discuss
and uh for those of you that are wanting
to participate in a project with an
intermediate enrollment you can
but the intermediate enrollment does not
give you enough time
so the training that will come first
will prepare you to design a project
proposal
but it will not give you enough time to
actually complete your project and so we
recommend having the advanced
uh subscription or if you already
have an intermediate enrollment also
consider joining the research fellowship
program
which will give you three to six months
to actually complete your project
yes thank you so much
and uh also i was getting the questions
from lb rn participants
so bioinformatics for precision medicine
is not
a program for the lbrn uh it is not
under
the programs under lbrn so if you would
want to
uh proceed your application for by
information precision medicine program
i'll just mail you all the details
and yes for those of you from lbrn that
want to participate in this program
in addition to other programs that you
are involved in
we can definitely take your information
and share it with the lbrn leadership
to see if they are going to provide some
kind of scholarship for you
but we do need to have your details for
that and we need to know for sure that
you are interested
and i know the praveen did you want to
ask something i'm sorry i think you were
interrupted
okay okay no problem
um nearby if you completed a
master's in bad technology you went to
learn bangkok without any pay program
yes you don't have to pay you can learn
a lot about bioinformatics on your own
for free there are many resources online
we provide some of the free
resources like introduction to
bioinformatics so please do take the
course introduction to bioinformatics
no cost completely free just make a
profile nearby
and start learning
okay excellent thank you everyone and
glad that all of you joined
and looking forward to seeing you again
next time
thank you so much everyone i'm just
dropping my mail id if you have any of
the dolls you
you can ask me it's marketing at the
refine dot bio or you can also find me
at uh mohit anthonypine.bio or
marketing at the rate or missouri.com
uh vinay yes i'll share the
i've added you to uh to the slack
channel already so please check your
mail id you would get the email from
uh the invitation for the slack channel
thank you jason
thank you everyone for joining we are
looking forward